you've done a complete turnaround in
your life because i was i was commenting
that someone like ozzy looks about 20
years younger
i mean the last time we met i was that
was that you were really messed up i was
really
dog on death doorman how'd you get off
everything did you do it yourself or did
you go to rehab i went to the betty
fords
yeah but the bottom of the line is if
you want to do anything in this world
you've got to really want to you got to
do it yourself you've got no you you
need help
right but the initial thing is i mean i
went to
you know my wife put me in betty ford
and this is a godzilla's truth
hoping that that would teach me to drink
like a gentleman
because i was like i was like a pirate
man i just got bar diving
like it would have been nice if you had
a few cocktails and could stop i go in
there with a like
i got george armani's suit and
everything i've got my tie and i'm ready
for to go you know right
so direct me to the cocktail a little
bar and they'll look at me as if i'm
just landing from mine
you go to betty ford and ask you for the
cocktail bar
and when they told you that's the only
way she could get me in the goddamn
place
oh she didn't tell you you have to be
dry yeah right i
cocaine syringes right yeah
pretty much i thought you were insane
they probably didn't even don't you know
where you're going
i know i'm going i'm because my the only
way my wife could get me to go in which
is look they'll teach you to do it
properly
right you know i thought i was doing it
wrong because i kept waking up in
weird and wild places right you said
well maybe there's a way
right well maybe there's a way that i
can learn how to drink maybe i should
drink like a gentleman just have a
couple of beers or something like this
that's what i went there for take one or
two loses then they go like
uh uh uh you can't have anything but
it's like the doors are closed
and then you can't get betty ford walks
in she's like it's like oh
betty ford actually shows up i was
supposed to spoke to a several occasions
really well i think i did
you mean betty ford and ozzy osbourne
like kind of had an encounter group
you have these wings you have these like
these different kind of like
some millionaire would donate a bunch of
doper
right right you know and have different
different kind of nightmare column d
swing these are
did you have a roommate did you have to
like share i was sharing with a
mortician
a mortician like this guy and he was
like he was a little nervous that i'm
going
you can't you can't you haven't got a
room on your own right oh and this guy
he's always crying i go
shut up shut up
why are you crying you're a big baby i
mean this guy's older than my dad man
my dad's been dead 50 years ago and the
guy's crying in the room
and he goes oh i'm so depressed i said
well why are you depressed
he said i work with dead bodies you're
in the right place
everybody's obvious in the ground yeah
yeah so this guy snored like
a full elephant i don't know the guy was
like
rattling the toilets so there you go for
some sleep and try to get on a normal
lifestyle and you can't sleep because
the guy's snoring
right then this they come to me one day
and they go through it look cause it's
all
a part of community you've got to help
people would they sit you in a group
and have you tell your problems oh yeah
you would tell your problems to people
i mean i mean what would you say you
would say i don't want to quit
but you know what i'm not dumb
you know you soon get the the gist of it
you know so you go
right you play along you just go oh yeah
oh yeah
anything to get out of there just just
get through this attorney stop
stop being in jail man right because you
really didn't want to quit drugs at that
point you had in other words what you're
saying but
at the end of the day yeah i did want to
quit i mean i i mean i just thought
i can't i can't i couldn't stand living
and i was afraid of dying
right you found motivation to quit i
mean i got too much to live for you know
right but when you're in that hole when
you're in that hole when you're
in a crap alley without a you know
it's it's a god awful place i mean so it
wasn't betty ford
the betty ford clinic they taught you
how to do that i might not get the i got
the
cats at home it was good five star four
stars
how many did you do all right now
well eventually it worked right you see
everybody don't think it's for real that
i don't get stolen anymore
i believe you i believe you so i mean do
you now go sit
with a psychiatrist or do you sometimes
really how is that sitting with a
psychiatrist
i had a psychiatrist and they gave me to
go when i first got
sober it's going ally in it and
my assistant tony would come along with
me i said i still go to tony
either i'm totally out of my mind or
this guy's doing his own gear
start talking out of his head do you
think the psychiatrist was on something
he was on drugs he's like he was
drinking
he had like a drawer full of drugs
really
[Music]
just take these and come back three
weeks later